Let's do another quiz about history predictors. Let's
say we have a program in which we have
two nested loops. One i goes from zero through
seven. And then within we have a nested loop
of j goes from zero through seven. Let's say
we do something that doesn't have much branching behavior
in it. This type of nested loop structure is
very common when you have things like matrices or
even image processing. In particular, for image processing, it's
very common. For example, compression or decompression are working in
blocks of, let's say, 8 by 8 pixels in this
case which will mean that there are loops like this
all over the code. Let's say that the code, when
it does this nested loop, just does something else and
then very quickly comes back to it to do another
round of this, so this is not just executed once,
the whole thing is executed many, many times. If we are building a history
based predictor that should do well on this code, it needs at least how many
entries, and each of these entries should
have, how many bits of history, and how
many 2 bit counters do we need to enter as a result of this history?